Cleveland Browns quarterback DeSean
Watson has returned to the field after
an 11-game suspension he played in his
first game of the season yesterday a win
over his former team the Houston Texans
Watson had some supporters in the stands
but others in the crowd booed him the
NFL sideline Watson in August after he
was accused of sexual misconduct by more
than two dozen women they say they were
abused during massage therapy sessions
Watson also was fined five million
dollars in order to undergo counseling
he was never charged with the crime Bill
Rhoden a columnist for ESPN's the
enscaped has covered this story for
months good morning Bill how are you
doing
hey good morning how are you doing I'm
doing good thank you for joining us now
Watson is eligible to play the remainder
of the Season given the accusations and
the fact that he was never charged with
a crime do you believe that the terms of
his suspension were enough
well I think I I I think a lot of
different things uh I I feel that he
probably should have been suspended for
the entire year
um you know but having having said that
uh he's being held accountable okay he's
being held accountable and I guess what
really outrages me now is is that
um you know the owners of the the
multi-billionaire owners of of the
Cleveland Browns aren't being held
accountable you know for you know for
paying him uh the multi-billionaire
owners of the Houston Texans are not
being held accountable you know for
helping to uh who are being complicit in
this Behavior it's not like they didn't
know this stuff was being happening so
seems like the only person being held
accountable is uh DeShaun Watson and he
is definitely being held accountable
he's going to be booed uh you know they
go to Cincinnati he's gonna he is being
held accountable but uh a lot of other
people aren't being held accountable and
that's that really what is what's I
think is outrageous
bill is he really being held accountable
I'm sitting here struggling with this as
Nate pointed out uh there have been 23
accusations he has not been formally
charged there's been several allegations
but I personally wouldn't want to work
with someone if someone said Nate and
Tony had 23 allegations from different
women and they were found you know not
guilty I would be very uncomfortable are
we just supposed to overlook all of that
and say well he's a great football
player so let him back on the field
there's something about that that
doesn't feel right to me either
well that you're right Gail there's no
there's no right parties in this he's
definitely wrong and should have
probably been suspended for the year but
also I guess what I'm saying is that
who's paying him who who he's been paid
the richest uh salary in in one of the
history of NFL football who did that who
who you know who who did that the
haslams the haslams they're the ones who
paid him you know so yeah I think that
we should flog uh DeShaun Watson but we
should also flog the multi-billionaire
owners who are paying him you see what
I'm saying and I guess I get that so
what message does that send if you're
really good in your job if you're really
good in sports because any other
industry this guy wouldn't even be
allowed to return to work any other
industry so what message does it say
you're a great player
yeah if you are a great player and we've
seen this at every single level of
sports if you are great your talent will
absolve you of a lot of accountability
um you know but I think that we have to
blame the adults you know you blame the
kid and you and you flog the kid but you
have to blame the people who are
allowing this to happen and I just don't
think we've done enough of that whether
it's Jerry Jones who owns the Cowboys I
don't think we've held him accountable
uh we haven't hold like I said we
haven't hold the owners of the of the
Texans accountable and we haven't held
uh the the owners of the Cleveland
Browns accountable and and I I guess
what frustrates me is how do you hold
multi-billionaires accountable and it's
not by you know they're the they're the
ones who are paying this guy you know so
I agree with you Gail uh and I think
that a lot of people could be wrong
desean's wrong uh the the Browns are
wrong for employing him yeah and Houston
was wrong for a nurse picture in it
Bill Rhoden we appreciate you thank you
for your honesty every time you join us
here on the show thank you Bill have a
good one